this is kingsley
hello gorgeous girl
hello you
first of all there's so much i want to
talk to you about but you have said that
your daughter is your best friend
you know when you think of all the
success that you've had especially
recently what kind of an influence do
you want to have on her
uh i just want her to know that uh
like my song said i just want to try and
be the best dad that can be and um
basically just teach her that she can do
whatever she puts her mind to and just
uh you know respect everybody
um
yeah
i like that did you expect her to give
you all the feels like everyone is like
oh you know we have a baby your whole
life changes we get it but like when you
actually have your baby are you like oh
so many feels yeah i will say i was
never like a big baby person and then i
had my baby and it's just changed the
way i look at other babies now
i guess
especially one that was that used to be
the size of her like when she was an
infant i just want to hold him just to
remember what it felt like
oh look at you look what she's done to
you yeah i know right
i love that well congratulations on your
new song blessed and free this is so
good i'm a huge fan of her i've
interviewed her before she's so cool how
did this whole collaboration come up
uh well it's funny because my wife is a
huge fan of her and that's what
introduced me to her and um our
our dance song our first dance song was
to uh her and daniel caesar's um and i
forgot the name of it best part
uh that was our first dance song and i
wrote this song like i want to say two
and a half or three years ago and um
just it was just kind of sitting on the
side for a little while and then my
manager texted me and said that her
jumped on it and wrote her own verse and
i just started freaking out because i
knew my wife loved her and then when i
listened to it like she just slayed the
song so
uh
that's how it came about i'm just pumped
she's on it now yeah well there's this
amazing video of you singing along to
this song i think it came out in april
of 2020 and you look so happy the
biggest smile on your face what is it
about this song that brings you so much
joy
um this song to me is just like uh
it's like i feel like artists especially
when honestly just people in general
they look for people's approval in a lot
of things
um
and this is just a song like an anthem
for people saying like you know we don't
need anybody's approval like we're
already blessed and free um just living
as people and it kind of it really
speaks to me what i've been going
through during this quarantine um
because then all social media and you
see
all kinds of different things um
and just people saying stuff so it's
like you know i'm blessing free whatever
yeah now hey that's such a good motto
and there's another couple of lyrics i
wanted to point out to you too i don't
count on nothing don't ever stop running
those really stood out to me and i was
wondering if that's essentially just
kind of your mod in terms of your career
and and just the mentality that you've
had to keep going
yeah i just uh i'm very competitive so i
don't ever try and stop and i always try
to uh you know out do what i've done in
the past and i feel like that's how you
keep get further in your career
well it's really cool you know because
last time i interviewed her like there
was just so much going on and she's
recently
been cast in the color purple adaptation
are you excited to see her acting
oh yeah um i would love to as well
because she's and we actually talked
about that uh in the video but she's
she kind of reminds me of myself as just
super laid back
um so i'm interested to see to see her
acting it'll be awesome
do you want to get in tactic
i'd love to but it's so hard for me to
to get myself out of this
persona when i'm just chilling unless
i'm on a stage
other than that it's it's something i've
been trying to work on
yeah do you feel like i mean essentially
you're acting when you're in your music
videos though right
yeah but i don't know it still has
something to do with my music if it was
if it was me you know trying to have to
act like somebody else i don't think
you know
i would love to try it though yeah okay
so then
seeing is how you said you'd love to try
it who would be on your bucket list if
you could start with any actor who would
you love to act opposite
um i would love to be
i don't know i don't necessarily have
somebody i would like to act with um
i do love chris pratt but i would have
to say like
uh i'd be in an avenger movie or like a
horror movie
ooh
both are like my favorite so that's
amazing avenger i mean you gotta hit the
gym i mean you're good but you know if
you're gonna be on like wires and and
then in a horror film you should do a
lot of screaming so you gotta you gotta
take care of that voice yeah well
i'd be the guy that uh
i'll leave immediately hopefully
you're you're out you're gonna be the
first one god
that's awesome um well this is such an
exciting time because your blessed free
tour same name of the tour is exciting
uh is about to kick off
how pumped are you for for so many stops
i'm super excited you know we just gotta
um we just finished our dates that uh
for last year when a pandemic happened
so
they were fun but it was um i don't know
if any other artists had this situation
but it was weird because the people were
holding their tickets for like 700 days
um so even though the shows were sold
out we weren't getting like the full
capacity we were getting like 85 or 90 i
don't know if people just forgot they
had tickets or yeah nervous still to go
um to the show or whatever but we just
put these tickets up uh for the new tour
and and um they're in all the nba arenas
which i'm super excited i get to do
because i'm a huge nba fan and then also
because we just put the tickets on uh up
and i think like april or something um
we know these fans probably want to be
there so i'm just excited to see you
know finally a full arena
that's so cool and so exciting for you
so exciting for the fans was it the goal
to be performing in all 29 nba arenas
yeah um
my team came to me with that uh
was it last year two years ago and we
didn't know if we could make it happen
and then we started talking to the nba
and and they've even helped us helped us
out a lot um you know what they're
advertising so it's been
uh it's been awesome and hopefully we
get to play
uh each at least one nba player from
each team
because uh jimmy butler called me out in
miami so
it'll be fun just to see how bad i am
compared to that yeah well you guys show
up
um okay so then when you stop in
toronto which i think will be in
november uh
have you invited any toronto raptors
uh no not yet
we haven't um i don't even think i've
got to come up there yet for the the
tour we've been going to tours and just
kind of getting
uh some footage of me being there before
the actual show and we haven't i don't
know yet so
okay well listen we know that drake is a
huge toronto raptors fan if you're gonna
go one-on-one with him in a game who do
you think would win
with drake
yeah me
no question huh no question i saw i've
watched some videos of him playing
not impressed
i'm not not impressed
that's amazing well i wanted to
congratulate you two on making the time
100 list
that i mean to be named one of the most
influential people of 2021 that's pretty
exciting how'd you react when you heard
that
uh it took me a second but um you know
now
it's just something that i'm so grateful
to be a part of
i've had a lot of
different kids come up to me and you
know say that they just
they look different and and they they
like country music and they feel out of
place when they listen to it like even
around their friends
and a lot of people that work with me
like my security and stuff like that and
people at the venues so it's been it's
been cool just to be able to
um to represent something different in
country music i love that now it was you
and dolly parton as the only country
singers representing on the the time 100
list right
yeah
i mean that's pretty wild
yeah no it's it's awesome i i didn't get
to see you know everybody's name up
there i didn't didn't look but um the
names that i did see over media it was
it was just you know crazy to be beside
of them um
so yeah
yeah
i mean that's wild and then it was
darris wrecker who did this write up for
you
yeah um
it it that that hit me too whenever he
said that i'm kind of doing you know
what what charlie pride was doing for a
lot of kids and and i did what he was
doing for a lot of kids um and then we
have other people coming up like like
jimmy allen and mickey gaitin as well
doing the same thing so
um
i don't know it's just it's just it's a
great time in country music right now
absolutely i was just talking to mickey
gaiden she's uh she's awesome
yeah she's uh she's strong
yeah definitely yeah we're talking about
our baby and you guys all have these
babies and you're juggling everything
you know so much has happened obviously
over the past year and a half but how
would you describe your life right now
my life right now i would say is uh it's
great
um you know i've always got my family
with me um we're fortunate enough to
have that and uh the shows are going
great um we have a lot of music waiting
to be released
and
i don't think life could be any better
right now
that's so nice because not everyone can
say that but i think that's so wonderful
i appreciate that and i need to know
what kingsley is up to right now what's
she doing she is eating lunch
[Laughter]
having a quesadilla
nice good choice